you have some feel of what is going to
be our area of interest but
that's going to ask you
ask you some general comments or would
you like me to go straight into the open
question
yeah I'm very happy to be guided by you
yeah
yeah all right dive in okay well my uh
the starting question anyway is is
um more open in its nature so perhaps I
could ask you how would you describe
your constitutional
contribution sorry your contribution to
constitutional matters over the
preceding year
well thank you and a pleasure to be here
before this uh committee
um there's obviously some day-to-day
stuff that just is constant and so I'm
in regular touch with the Judiciary uh
including the law chief justice uh
obviously the president the Supreme
Court the
uh the SBT
um
in particular I suppose we spend quite a
bit of time talking to the president the
family law division because there's
quite a lot going on there and with all
the financial implications and the
Concord out process with which you'll be
well versed obviously I'm constantly
talking about the things that need to be
done to uphold the concordat
um more more specifically I suppose I
would include in terms of stuff that
we've done over the last year or so the
judicial review and courts Act
and the reforms entailed in that
including the cart route we've published
a Bill of Rights and I suspect that has
particular constitutional impacts from
the provisions reinforcing Free Speech
through to the treatment and I know
we're coming on to talk about the Bill
of Rights but things like sections two
and three and what that means for the
separation of powers I think that's
quite an interesting constitutional
aspect on top of all what effective is
the retail political uh site or
dimension of the HRA and the Bill of
Rights
um covid recovery and the backlog that's
obviously something that I have to
engage with the Judiciary on we have the
hmcts board which again as well as
dealing with the nuts and bolts of what
we're doing particularly in relation to
a covert recovery is about really the
relationship with the Judiciary
um and I just I suspect that's probably
enough for the the in terms of what
we've done over the last year
um what
some of those points
you come on to more specific questions
backlog Bill of Rights Family Law Court
but um
and but going looking forward what would
you put as your top priority is looking
forward
first of all maintaining that
relationship is very important
um uh we're obviously recruiting uh the
next law chief justice and perhaps it
would be an opportune moment for me to
put on record as I have done elsewhere
um my tributes personally to the work
that the current law chief justice has
done uh both
um in terms of the court of appeal but
also more generally the approach uh to
as a guardian of the Constitution I
think we've been blessed with a
particularly fine law Chief Justice at a
particularly challenging moment in time
and uh I I'm glad to put that on the
record
in contrier terms if I can put it like
that we've also got the Bill of Rights
that's introduced uh look forward to
passing that through the House of
Commons and then engaging in a civilized
conversation with uh uh uh in the other
place
um and I'm sure there'll be plenty of
discussions around that
um parole reform the parole board is
viewed as a quasi-judicial function it's
quite an interesting theological
argument about what proboard does
both in terms of constitutionally but
also in terms of public protection
um and you'll have seen the reforms that
we've consulted on and we are very close
to producing the legislative legislation
in relation to that
um we've also got retention of EU law
the opportunities to shape that caucus
of law according to UK needs rather than
a blanket approach on the other hand and
I would admit that needs to be
juxtaposed with the needs for legal
certainty getting that balance right I
think is going to take up a fair amount
of my time
um so those are I think the key things
that I see on on the horizon
um as you probably are aware that we
have produced recently our report on the
rose of the Lord Chancellor and the Lord
Law Officers and we concluded in that
that the Lord Chancellor should fulfill
a wider cross-departmental role in
defending the rule of law and educating
his or
her colleagues on the importance how do
you approach your duty to the rule of
law
so it's interesting I I and I've and I
read the report and uh I was very happy
to respond to it the
the bottom line is I don't look at it as
a sort of um uh uh a statutory challenge
there's no Gap
um and it probably helps as having the
role of Deputy Prime Minister have an
overarching view of what's going on I
have regular conversations with the
attorney general
um that's a very fruitful relationship
was under the previous attorney it is
now
um I often dip my toe into various
different things as DPM but obviously
where there is any legal or
constitutional Dimension I think
obviously expected to to comment in
cabinet or in right rounds or more
generally so I would say it was an
empirical an inductive approach rather
than a Cartesian approach if I can put
it like that but I don't really see any
problem with it
um the the and and we have I think a
prime minister who is quite scrupulous
about doing things the correct way and
that is always a good way to approach
um constitutional issues so if that
sounds like a very malleable or flexible
approach I I would hope is actually a
more effective one
um and we're very careful when the
legislation that comes through and we
have a busy legislative agenda an
ambitious one to make sure that we are
protecting the Constitution but also
I've got the confidence to reform it
where that is required and the judicial
review courts Bill and now Act and the
Bill of Rights are good examples of that
so I think we should be confident about
doing that in a typical British and
pragmatic way and that's the way I
approach it within cabinet more
generally
I think the Northern Ireland protocol
bill I suppose raised issues about
um your role in those circumstances but
I think Lord bought me you wanted to ask
a question yeah thank you very much
deeper coming Lord Chancellor
um I took from that answer you've just
given that you do accept that Lord
chancellor has got some wider role than
other ministers in relation to
protecting the rule of law yes in
relation to the northern Irish protocol
Bill not the one that we're talking
about now but in the middle of 2022 the
justification for breaking International
agreement that Britain had entered into
the UK had entered into was the doctrine
of necessity it was described as
there was no option but necessity to
break the deal that had been done a few
years before were you specifically
consulted about that what role did you
regard the Lord Charter as having to
play in that issue which involved
breaking an international agreement on
the face of it
is I probably wouldn't accept the
characterization you gave but to
understand the question
um look first and foremost we have an
attorney general we've got an
exceptional attorney general we had
previously an exceptional attorney
general one one thing I would just say
um I don't think it's the job of the law
Chancellor to be a court of appeal on
the Attorney General's advice
um it is to assess it to scrutinize it
to discuss it uh I have long and uh
fascinating conversations with attorney
general's past and present and But
ultimately That's the Law Office role
I'm not sure the rule of law of the
Constitution will benefit from me trying
to use my role in the way you described
not not saying you suggest this but to
be a court of appeal if you like or to
try and trespass what I would always do
is want to understand the granular
detail of it which is what I did on the
bill
um and also
effectively rather than second guess to
support the attorney of the day in
making sure that the wider
constitutional equities that are
reflected in their view of the legal
advice are protected and preserved so
it's a curious double act and uh but I
think it works in practice again uh in
in as much of our constitution is
Unwritten I actually I think it works
well in practice it probably does depend
on the person I mean you'll remember it
probably does depend on the
personalities
um but I think as long as you uh develop
a modus operandi uh I think it can be
quite effective you described yourself
as having a good relationship with the
current attorney general you said unlike
the previous one no Sudan as well as
sorry I apologize just a crystal clear I
have an exceptional relationship with
Zoella Bradman uh and an exceptional
relationship with the current AG
Victoria printers did you work together
with the then Attorney General on the
necessity issue well again uh it's not
for me if you like and we often do this
don't we in government we seek council's
opinion at the attorney will and
sometimes you seek multiple accounts as
opinion it's not for me to put myself in
as either junior or senior Council in
that relationship or what I think it is
right to do is once the attorney with or
without council's opinion has assessed
scrutinized and then put pen to paper is
to test the ideas
in fan is quite a lot of other ministers
will do the same whether or not they
have the August title of Lord Chancellor
but I think that it's understood
um that there's a constitutional role
for the Royal Chancellor in doing so
which is natural and healthy
um I think both attorney generals are
very expert but also confident and that
breeds a willingness to engage which is
um again going back to personalities I
think that helps can you give us an
example of where in your role as Lord
Chancellor
defending the rule of law you've
intervened it's probably not right for
me to do so if I haven't already made it
public for various different reasons but
I think as little Chancellor I don't
know whether you would agree with this
from your uh experience
um but you want to protect the
discretion of the advice you give and
sometimes you won't if I thought uh
if I thought there was an overt attack
on the Judiciary I would be plain
speaking and public in my correction of
that it's not for HMG to do and we
haven't had that in my time as a little
Chancellor um but I'm very mindful of
that
um if I thought that there was anything
that might lead to that I would also
probably try and nip it in the bud early
I haven't had calls to do so but most of
my advice is given quietly and hopefully
assiduously and is I think as with the
wide doctrine of cabinet Collective
responsibility those discussions are
held privately I think they're more
effective and more rigorous as a result
of that
to one of your identified priorities the
Bill of Rights bill and
um the implications for UK being a party
to the European convention on human
rights I think Lord Thomas you had an
opening question on that issue yes the
Bill of Rights bill is intended to
overhaul the Human Rights Act explicitly
soon and quotes restore the balance of
power between the legislature and the
courts
um in your view which elements of the
Human Rights Act fail to maintain the
balance of power in the legislature and
the courts and can I say this to you um
in your Bill of Rights you say you you
provide this a court may not adopt a
post-commencement interpretation of a
convention right that would require a
public authority to comply with a
positive obligation
and um everybody's always thought of the
convention
as a living instrument which adapts and
adopts to the to the current situation
but um you particularly in advising in
the bill that people look at the
proprietary documents to the convention
which presumably were in 1948 or 49.
you're an originalist as the Americans
would say as opposed to
treating the Bill of Rights the the
Convention as a living instrument
yes
we could have a wonderful Symposium on
on the question that you've asked it is
uh far-reaching look um so I don't
accept your proposition around the
living instrument living instrument is
not contained in the echr
um and of course if you look at what
judge Spano the the uh outgoing
president of the Strasbourg court has
said is that the Strasbourg Court the
European Court of human rights has
shifted from an age where they did look
creatively uh at the Uchi and their
interpretations as a living instrument
to an age of subsidiarity it'll be a
very interesting question I was in
Strasbourg recently what the new
president for whom I have uh great
regard
um how how she approaches it
um but the living instrument let's be
very clear and I'll speak candidly so we
understand what it was something that is
not rooted in the convention and
involves a creativity with no Democratic
mandate
um it's actually different from the
Human Rights Act in that respect Human
Rights Act licenses all sorts of
creativity but in thin is I think the
Judiciary under uh
a little Bingham would have said well
Parliament gave us this power and it was
for Parliament to change in relation to
the Strasbourg Court the doctrine living
instrument was conjured out of case law
um and I think therefore that what the
Germans would call the grunt Norm of
that is very much open to question
um
I would also note that the Strasbourg
case law has ebbed recently in its
creativity and has taken a more
constrained approach of course what Ebbs
May flow and it is a perfectly
legitimate question the extent to which
any court domestic or International is
creating law as opposed to applying law
now of course facts change as you said
um and facts change over time and case
law will therefore have to adapt to it
but it is quite an important distinction
even if it's a subtle one applying law
existing law to new facts as opposed to
creating new law it is
undeniable that the European Court of
human rights under the living instrument
Doctrine has created new law it is also
undeniable that there is no provision in
the convention that allows for it
um
I don't think that that is a literalist
approach uh or a A in the way you
described but I do think uh being very
careful about the separation of powers
is important in terms of the Human
Rights Act it's a rather different
creature but it does allow the
importation of that creativity and
through for example sections two and
section three
um in particular section three which I
do think is pernicious it allows for the
amendment of legislation by the courts
in order to force compliance not just
with echr but without ever expanding
Corpus of Strasbourg case law I think
that's wrong constitutionally in
principle uh I suspect at the time if we
look back I I don't think it was the
intention of The Architects the HRA but
I would I refer to
others who are there at the time on that
um and I do think that's right for
reform sections two section three
um uh and you asked another element of
the question which sorts Escape me but
um I think it's absolutely legitimate
forget the changes and the the the
things that happen for example
um uh the the creeping expansion of
article eight to make it more difficult
to deport foreign National offenders or
the ongoing challenges I have now in
prison with people suing I mean it's
extraordinary we have under article 8
terrorist Defenders convicted terrorist
offenders suing uh HMG for a right to
socialize in prison where we deem them a
risk in terms of disseminating either
extremist material or uh terrorist
recruitment I find that extraordinary
and that's direct example of that
creativity so and and finally that was
the issue you asked me about the travel
preparator and you and I think if I
understood you Lord Thomas and I don't
want to characterize or mischaracterize
what you suggested was that somehow that
was an inappropriate thing to do as a
Canon of international law including
under any Convention of law of treaties
it is particularly when there's a gray
area of law which I often talking about
is precisely legitimate not only that a
lawful thing to do to look at the travel
Preparatory to define the meaning of a
particular provision of treaty I hope
I've given a full and not unduly
defensive answered your question I'll
just give room for a great debate on
this yes I have a little bit of a queue
of people on this issue so I should be
more disciplined in my answer no no no
no no it wasn't it wasn't your answer at
all it was my making sure that or they
were Lords who want to ask you a
question on this can be fitted into the
time available Lord Fuchs do you want to
ask your question yes I'd like to take
you to a different I don't hope I'm just
calling you on board
thank you good morning uh Lord
Chancellor uh
I followed you in Strasbourg visiting
the court of human rights as part of the
delegation the UK delegation to the
Parliamentary assembly and we were given
the same statistics that you were given
that the United Kingdom in fact there
are the fewest complaints of any country
that member country and last year of 260
complaints 255 were ruled out uh as are
inappropriate to be dealt with by the
court only five were considered and only
two of those were found
to be dealt with by the court one of
which I think was in relation to the uh
the uh
Rwanda case so it's a very very small
number and you've rightly said that
the
United Kingdom has no the government has
no uh contemplation of leaving uh the uh
Convent of coming out of the convention
of Human Rights will you confirm that
today
thank you very much
um look we have got a very good record
and we should be proud of our record not
just of compliance but also founder
members of the European Court of human
rights in Strasbourg the international
criminal court I'm doing a lot of work
just I know it's an aside but a lot of
work with Kareem karak Khan a British
prosecutor the ICC Joanna Corner was
elected as well an exceptional
um uh Advocate and now judge
um we should be proud of our record
um equally uh there are moment where
indeed the Strasbourg case law and the
principle of uh the marginal
appreciation call for dialogue it is not
an illegitimate thing to test
particularly given those amorphous
parameters of case law and the fact that
there isn't a strict doctrine of
precedent in Strasbourg it is absolutely
legitimate to press and we did it on
prisoner voting and everyone told me we
kicked out the Council of Europe I was
the junior minister at the Minister of
Justice and under David women and people
said that we'd be expelled from the
Council of Europe and that would or that
we had to give Prisoners the vote I went
over and I had a conversation with the
committee ministers we didn't give
Prisoners the vote
um and we didn't fall out of the echi
and I made clear at the time our respect
for the institutions and this idea that
you have to
um and it's perhaps a peculiar British
or I should say English and Welsh
phenomenon as common law countries
particularly common law countries that
we think we um we all operate to a
doctrine of precedent whereas it isn't
really the way Continental domestic
systems let alone the international
Courts at work and our ability to
challenge sometimes is right and the
marginal appreciation recognizes on your
particular point and the Bill of Rights
I think encapsulates that but within the
bounds of the convention and the the
government's position on the echr is as
I make clear in relation to Bill of
Rights is that we would intend to stay a
state party indeed we retain the echi in
a schedule if you're asking me whether
we're committed forever and a day to
stay with an echr the answer is that's
not commitment that we've able to make
and that depends a little bit on the
court but I I made the point when I was
in Strasbourg that we feel
more not less committed to the Council
of Europe as a result of brexit I think
we've shown our European credentials in
relation to Ukraine what we do in NATO
it's not a question of rejecting Europe
in fact I actually see the counts of
Europe as an opportunity not just in
terms of the court but some of the other
work they do for example raising Fair
trial standards good opportunity to show
we can be an even stronger European
neighbor that's very helpful but you
haven't said
quite clearly that there is the
government policy current policy is that
there is no intention to withdraw no
it's out meticulously incorrectly and
accurately precisely the government's
position yes I'm happy to do so again
right and because it's very important in
relation to the other countries which
have a a far worse record than we do uh
in relation to Human Rights I agree but
I was a bit frustrated that with our
record in the way you described and our
Democratic credentials uh that there is
any suggestion of moral equivalence with
other countries I mean for example
before Russia was expelled the idea that
because we kicked up a fast over
prisoner voting we put on the par with
Russia I mean if anyone is I mean we
just need to be careful of that I also
unders I mean I understand the point
you're making that setting a good
example and maintaining high standards
is important and sends a message to the
world so former foreign secretary as
well as the current all chance I get
that but the suggestion that if we push
back at the margin of on something like
prisoner voting we somehow On a par with
Russia which is sometimes the argument
here honestly we need a little bit of a
stronger moral campus yeah we're getting
delegates from other countries raising
with us the fact that the Home Secretary
says that she wants the UK to withdraw
and that undermines our position what
can be done to stop the Home Secretary
uh saying that and get her to stick to
government policy fundamental principle
of the echr and quintessentially British
right is to express yourself freely
particularly in the course of a
leadership concept but not Lord folks
can we I just we've got some really
important points still on this okay
question if I may
um I know Lord hope you wanted to raise
some points on the Human Rights Act in
the Constitutional settlement do you
want yes can I take good morning and can
I take you a completely different
aspective which was the target place in
the duvolution arrangements yes across
the devolved administrations as you know
the legislatures of all three default
administrations cannot act or legislate
incompatibly with the convention and the
convention also affects the powers of
ministers because they can't act
incompatibly with the human rights act
now the Bill of Rights the Bill of
Rights as I understand it is to apply
across all four parts of the UK and I
think I'm right in saying that you're
proposing to amend the default
settlements by simply changing the large
Human Rights Act to the Bill of Rights
or Bill of Rights act as it will be is
that right
um or the Bill's been published so you
can see that the name but I mean just
more generally
uh that the position uh on the evolution
is that the HRA is a uk-wide piece of
legislation it's not actually reserved
power but this is a protected enactment
under the Devolution settlements so any
amending of it can only be for the
parliament in Westminster
of course the devolved legislatures can
before and after legislate on human
rights issues within the Ambit of their
devolved competencies to that extent
there is already some measure of
variable geometry in relation to Human
Rights and I think that's natural and it
follows from the devolved settlements
it's also quite similar in other common
law jurisdictions I think to to a degree
in Canada for example
um in terms of our approach
um to the Sewell convention which I
think you were touching on as well but
but correct me if I'm wrong
okay well in that case I will not tread
Where Angels will not get trespass
Rangers Fear To Tread entirely a
separate issue
um can I raise the question of the The
Good Friday agreement yes because I
don't think you can change the Good
Friday agreement and there's no attempt
in the bill as I understand it to do
that the the good writer group is quite
simple and straightforward it simply
states that
uh the government is incorporating the
convention into Northern Ireland
providing for direct access to the
courts and remedies for breach of the
convention so
um the the way in which you the bill is
changing the balance between the courts
and the legislatures
um I don't think affects the working of
the Good Friday agreement you're
absolutely right in that I share that
interpretation I'm heartened by your uh
your your your take on it as well yes
well the reason I've introduced this is
that it has been suggested by some
people that that would create a risk of
confusion between two different
approaches to the convention you've got
the the reform situation which the Bill
of Rights would create and particularly
in regard to free speech and so on where
there's a very important change in the
balance which you're proposing and then
can I say the very simple and
straightforward approach in the Belfast
agreement is there a risk of confusion
don't believe there is any more than
currently as a result of the
um
devolved settlements but the truth is
we we don't have I mean the evolved
settlements are obviously enacted but we
don't have
um if you like an overarching written
Constitution and and I'm not suggesting
we trespass into that and therefore what
we've tended to do is deal with these
issues bit by bit
um and I think the Bill of Rights
preserves
um a certainly in relation to Northern
Ireland uh the the right balance of
power and certainly we've been very
careful in the drafting to avoid any
impingement on The Good Friday agreement
I'll ask about article six yes
convention that's played a major part in
Scotland and reforming the way in which
criminal prosecutioners are handled is
there any suggestion of change to the
way the courts apply article six
in in uh Scotland or more generally well
Scotland in particular of course but
this was a huge amount of case law built
on article six and um and I'm not quite
sure what if anything you're proposing
but to change the balance between the
courts in relation to the interpretation
of article 6 which has been of great
benefit to the proper handling of
criminal prosecutions in Scotland would
be a significant change
we've set out in the Bill of Rights our
approach to the procedural framework
including
um section six I don't believe it would
have it would risk any of the
consequences that you say but I'd be
very happy if you wanted to write to me
with any particular concerns to respond
very carefully
I don't have a particular point I'm not
really just searching generally that
you're aware of the fact that article 6
has played a major part in reforming the
way criminal prosecutions are handled to
the benefit of the system and I wouldn't
want to change that I would have thought
Point well registered okay we may take
you up on your offer thank you we um
I've just got other pressing questions
just two more questions and then we'll
move on there's Lord Howard and Lord
Anderson have got questions Lord Howard
good morning Lord Chancellor just to set
the record straight Lord Thomas said
that everyone agrees that the convention
is a living instrument you have made it
clear that that is not the case and you
are not alone in dissenting from that
proposition
um one of the problems with Human Rights
Act
is that it invites our judges
to decide on issues of proportionality
something which uh some of us at least
thought should be the job of elected
politicians to decide
to what extent will the the Bill of
Rights
modify the extent to which our judges
will continue to receive that invitation
I think there are lots of areas but
um let me try a couple
um
um I think sometimes we will explicitly
qualify a right to avoid expansive
interpretations articulate is the
obvious example In fairness and uh I
think article 8 paragraph two does
invite States parties to do that it is a
positive right set out with a series of
qualifications which I think exactly as
you've said Lord Howard are
the precise balance up to a point as
long as you're not emasculating the
writer for elected legislative elected
an accountable legislative to decide so
that's one way of doing it there are
other areas where we actually strengthen
rights I mean free speech we want to
reinforce I think that's a
quintessentially UK right uh it has been
challenging lots of different ways
people talk about wokery but but I also
think of Judge made Privacy Law uh that
is quite contrary to a British uk-wide
tradition of transparency and
accountability in any event uh of course
uh strengthening free speech I think uh
both in its own right and in its
balancing with other things like
rasculate is a legitimate thing to do
more generally
um uh
sections two and three of the HRA
preventing the elastic case law in
Strasbourg from automatically being
ported
um section uh three whereby effectively
you invite courts to amend legislation I
think are areas where the the procedural
framework will be considerably tightened
um again I make the point that I know my
I can see uh Lord Anson twitching at my
reference to section two of course the
case law as in Strasbourg has epped
um it's not for me to comment on uh the
Supreme Court uh in terms of uh the the
merits of its approach but I think as a
matter of fact uh a lot of commentators
are free that it has taken a much more
strained restrained approach than
previous courts under previous
compositions
um of course it's also the case that if
you curtail section three you may invite
more Declarations of incompatibility
you may well end up in Strasbourg a
little bit more I think it's at the
margins but I think that's quite healthy
I think it's healthy because in exactly
the way you describe is for elective
parliamentarians to wrestle with
socioeconomic questions or precise
balances and it's for the course say
hold on you've impinged on the
fundamental right it's not for the court
then to dive in rewrite the legislation
I'm not criticizing the courts not only
because of the shift in approach but
also because the HRA explicitly license
and requires them to do so I hope that
gives you just a broad outline of the
approach we don't have a written
separation of powers in the UK
Constitution and and I'm not suggesting
we we do that it's not a very British
uk-wide approach it's not a particularly
common law approach it doesn't I don't
think that means we should abdicate the
importance of the separation of powers I
want robust judges uh I think we've got
world-beating Judiciary we want robust
judges taking robust approaches but
understanding the limits of their powers
and likewise the executive needs to be
held to account and the legislative
needs to perform its role properly
thank you Lord Anderson a little bit of
gravity at this point would be helpful
Lord Anderson thank you I will be brief
and I think your last answer if I may
say so went right to the Constitutional
heart of the Bill of Rights
um you mentioned section three which of
course is a section that allows the
judges to interpret statutes in a way
that Parliament didn't necessarily
intend I understand that you describe
that as pernicious because you think
that is the judge trespassing onto the
functions of parliament my first
question I think you've answered I was
going to ask you whether you thought
that if you got rid of section three
there were going to be more Declarations
of incompatibility by the courts and I
think you accepted just now that there
will be more
but my second question again is a
constitutional question
that has I think it would be fair to
describe it
um there has been a convention over the
past 20 years or so that when there is a
declaration of incompatibility and the
government has appealed it
unsuccessfully right to the top then the
government will change the law uh in
obedience to the judges which has
declared the law to be incompatible with
the Human Rights Convention what I'm
asking you is whether you anticipate
that that convention will remain as
Declarations of incompatibility become
more common after your bill comes into
force and section three has been
repealed thank you and another a very
legitimate and articulate Challenges
ever
um by the way I don't think let me just
be honest between us as as colleagues
and uh I don't accept that section three
is purely about interpretation it is
about amending legislation and that is
what the power does in effect I
understand that sometimes the the the
there's a vanishing point between
reputation to new facts and in fact
changing the rules I I've got no doubt
that the combination of sections three
and two has at least previously resulted
in that kind of amendment legislation
and that is the point of principle
um will we end up with more Declarations
of incompatibility maybe at the margins
but of course government will address
its approach to the new settlement so uh
there was
of course only under previous labor
governments I hasten tired but perhaps a
little bit of laziness in the drafting
of legislation
um I'm teasing Lord Faulkner but a
little bit of laziness in where if
something was a bit rough around the
edges quietly it was always understood
that the cause would refine it I I I
don't think that's an honest approach I
don't think it's a correct approach
um and I'm sure Lord Falcon would may
take issue with it but there was there
is certainly a sense of within that
particularly hyperactive legislative
period in the naughties
um uh that well you know lots of stuff
coming onto the statute but but the
courts would straighten it out and by
the way we've given them the tools to do
so I think that's wrong
so I I'm not clear that the the that
correcting that would necessarily lead
to more Declarations of incompatibility
it could lead to more thoughtful
legislation
but if there are declaration sequence
this is my question will the government
comply with them or will they leave it
to Australia to be honest with you
Lawrence I was trying to whittle away at
your assumptions so I didn't have to
give a particularly long answer the more
tricky question that you've given me but
um but the the truth is I'm not sure
that there is a convention the way you
describe but certainly a practice
ultimately and we spell this out in a
Bill of Rights it's Parliament to write
the laws of the land uh the reality is
whatever we say about the procedural
consequences of Declaration of
incompatibility you've got to remain
consistent with your International
locations and I'm not suggesting
otherwise but what you effectively do is
Parliament must take responsibility for
that both in the terms of the choice and
on whether to legislate and quite how
nuanced it wants to be because
Parliament can always take a view
there's three options about how we
comply with the Judgment we'll take the
minimalist approach let's see how that
goes and that's part of the dialogue of
strategory that's a legitimate thing to
do ultimately Palmer also must decide
um if it's not going to comply whether
it wishes to withdraw from the
convention and a lot of that will depend
on the wisdom of legislators and the
government but also on the approach
taken in Strasbourg and I think that
relationship is a perfectly legitimate
lawful and healthy one to have
of course we'd lose our trade and
cooperation agreement particularly in
relation to criminal justice wouldn't be
with the EU if we were to actually
withdraw from the convention without
speculation it's not it's written in the
TCA you know whether they would exercise
what was in the TCA the the
um I mean but look we've got ourselves
into a good place this week or
relationships with our EU friends and
partners that's not I don't say anything
um uh that puts that at risk I want a
good relationship with EU I want a good
relationship in the council Europe I'm
the father of a Czech Refugee I feel
very passionately European and I also
feel very passionate as a Democrat
okay thanks very much if we could um
move on to criminal funding of criminal
legal aid and uh potential implications
for administration of justice Lord
Faulkner we had a question
um the Bellamy report which the Lord
chances Department accepted said the
problem in relation to criminal legal
aid was in order to have a properly
functioning Criminal Justice System you
needed to have a sustainable
fence solicitors and barristerial
profession that could provide equality
of arms for defendants
um says Christopher proposed 135 million
increase in the pay for criminal defense
lawyers as a first stage in trying to
put the criminal defense side of the
equation back into an okay State he
describing it as being in a very very
bad state
and he's saying it's not a sustainable
um profession the defense bar profession
including solicitors unless something
substantial is done and he described 135
million as the first step
how do you view the state of criminal
defense at the moment and what further
steps you're going to take to put it
onto a sustainable and better position
thank you uh little folk look I I first
of all pay tribute to Lord Bellamy
um we were so impressed with his report
we made him a minister albeit not with
responsibility for criminal legal aid
um and I think he's an exceptional job
um we also published our response we've
boosted the system with The Upfront
investment uh 15 for most fees
um this is alongside the wider long-term
reforms that he recommended and actually
takes the total increase in spending to
over 135 million to uh it'll be up to
138 million that takes the criminal
legal aid expenditure on an annual basis
to 1.2 billion pounds a year
um we're also separately looking at
civil legally but I know your question
was in relation to crimley Glade I think
we need to see how the system settles
down obviously we monitor those areas
geographically which have more of a
challenge in finding
um criminal legal aid lawyers and there
are some structural issues around access
to the profession
and advocacy rights and that we also
need to look at very carefully but we've
come in and and you know this this issue
I think In fairness had been long
overdue
um we own it it's our
policy and our review but I think the
legal aid system have come on a
challenge for under under successive
governments and we've taken important
step in investing in it to make it fit
for the future
um there will be more challenges and
we'll we'll look at them prospectively
but I think actually we've set the
foundations now for a sustainable
criminal legal profession I mean there's
nothing in that answer if I'm interested
with respect uh Lord Bellamy made it
clear that it was the first step I'm
interested to know what the second and
third and fourth steps are
me set out and they were phased in terms
of the immediate financial uplift and
then the structural reforms so the
structural reforms that you're you're
well versed in they're all uh under
underway and I'm happy to look at the
second third and fourth steps but I
think it makes sense to see how
effective the first step has been and
how short footed uh before we decide
what scale of further intervention is
required and we've just put a massive
amount in
um the idea the idea that we have a low
expenditure on criminal legal aid given
the figures I've just set out I think I
think I would want to challenge
um but we'll we'll keep looking at it if
you've got any particular forms you
think we need to be considering I'm
always willing to consider it
at a particularly financially stricken
time
thank you you must have some contingency
plans if you continue to see sustained
declined in the number of
solicitors engaged in continued legal
aid work we've got the we've got we've
got the public defender regime we've got
other opportunities and there is always
the opportunity to look at the
settlement again in theory I think in
reality given the financial strictures
that's very unlikely to produce any
extra money
I do think it needs structural reform
um and of course
I think my experiences people are more
likely to come forward with propositions
to increase the budget than to change
and reform the system
um I would also say though I I think uh
with Kirsty brimellow
um who I've met with and it's very
serious and concerted there is also an
opportunity to engage with the CBA in a
different way a more constructive way
and certainly as a secretary of state
and the Royal Chancellor I greatly
welcome that
I think you had
you had those three questions I was
involved in the um at the beginning in
supporting the public defender scheme
but it is still a minute part of these
services or not
it's a small proportion uh not least
because there's so much opposition from
within the profession to it you referred
to advocacy rights
and of course that immediately makes
criminal barristers feel that um you are
going to
possibly enhance the position of uh
solicitor Advocates is is that within
your contemplation I wouldn't regard as
enhancing so much as leveling the
playing field I came come at this as
um I trained as a competition lawyer way
back when
um and I I suppose I look at it a little
bit like that and and I think we need to
be clear what our priority is our
priority is the consumer of Legal Aid
Services uh of course we recognize the
role of the practitioners they're
they're abs are instrumental but our
overarching duty is the public that
benefit from the service but we've just
talked about two things the public
defender service and advocacy rights
solicitors and you're quite right
um whenever we talk about anything other
than money there's a huge opposition for
within the sector
yes well you would presumably want to
see a skilled bar criminal bar still in
existence wouldn't you yes of course and
I would also like to say diversity of
provision which gives us as we talk we
talk about Supply chains even covid but
a diverse uh profession uh with enough
resilience built into it
and Lord Bellamy is saying don't change
the structure fundamentally make sure
the one that currently exists works
properly
he was saying if you only did the 135
million which you've done that wouldn't
be enough and I'm reading your answers
Lord Chancellor as being you'll wait and
see how the 135 million goes down and
then you'll make a decision which
doesn't seem to me to be in line with
what Lord Bellamy was saying I I allow
me to respectfully disagree first of all
um into there's a short and long term or
short meeting and long term his
short-term recommendations we followed
almost entirely including the money and
the only thing I didn't do was on paying
for pages of uh prosecution evidence
because I think that creates a perverse
incentive actually the only two things
really
um structurally which I didn't agree
with
anything which created incentive to
create paperwork anything that's
centered created an incentive to prolong
hearings and those are the only two
things of all the recommendations is for
my collection that we are suggesting
some things that in prolonged hearings
I think he was suggesting it
um but I wanted to be very careful that
if we looked at the reforms across the
board that we didn't allow that to
happen and the exception exceptions that
I made to accepting the recommendations
were those two is by regulation but look
in terms of The Next Step so we've done
exactly what uh with more or less
exactly what Lord Bellamy had suggested
but in terms of the next stage
um that is a medium and longer term and
I think given the amount of change that
has come through uh at quite a
breathless Pace notwithstanding that I
know that it took a long time
development reviewed to actually uh
conclude him for the government to
respond In fairness I came back with it
very quickly
um within within months I published it
and that was what the CBA advised me to
do and then we've as quickly as we
physically could introduce the reforms I
think given the scale of that it's right
to just pause for reflection and see
what further is required no at least
given there are some pretty big
questions or in relation to structural
reforms
foreign
leaves us a little concerned but let's
see how we go with the next question
um civil legal aid Lord Anderson you
wanted to yes thank you um the ministry
of justice has recently launched a
review of civil legal aid with a final
report due in 2024.
um the president of the Law Society
recently told the Justice Committee in
the Commons over the past five years
over half of civil legal aid firms have
left the profession and the chair of the
bar said recently that unless interim
measures are put in place to shore up
existing provision there will be no
system left by 2025. well that sounds
quite alarming
um are they right and if so do you have
any interim measures in mind or indeed
any structural plan that might allow the
money to go further
but I mean first of all we're um as well
as undertaking the review of civil legal
aid we've had the means test review
um and that expanding the scope dramatic
significantly I don't have the figures
here but I'm happy to write back if it's
helpful Lord Anderson
um there's always a balance between
doing the analysis rigorously and
swiftly
um but I I think we need to have the
conclusion of the review if there are
some things that jump out as low-hanging
fruit uh that we or Essentials that
can't wait that long of course I'd be
willing to consider it at least
in relation to private law family cases
uh uh civil legal aid was quite
dramatically slashed sometime
considerably before you became at Lord
Chancellor what work has your department
done to see what the effect has been on
clearly vulnerable families but also the
amount of court time that is taken up by
people not having lawyers many people
say it makes the process longer and more
expensive because the judges have to
spend longer dealing with those cases
yes I I private um it's my fourth Tour
of Duty in the ministry of justice and
I've always had some Locus to look at
private family law and public family law
In fairness private family law
effectively the situation and I'll just
tell you what I think there is about 55
of the cases that end up in the courts
which are safeguarding and domestic
abuse I think they must have a lawyer uh
sorry a judge dealing with them I think
in relation to the other 45 percent
effectively uh
separation of assets and custodial
Arrangements uh I I think we should be
actively discouraging
um those cases from coming to court they
ought to settle before so what are we
doing about it I think and this probably
touches on the the financial issue as
well we're investing a huge amount in
the mediation and the vouchers to
support it and the thing I want to do is
to encourage uh ADR but make mediation
to resolve those issues without going to
court aside from the financial saving I
think for those families and in
particular for the children that are are
otherwise going to court is a much much
better outcome I mean it is agonizing to
drag children through that process the
the the question the interesting
question is the extent to which the
vouchers and the mediation will work
there is already significant evidence
from the pilots and the scheme that they
do work and therefore I think it's a
good example of something where we all
to invest and not just to save money but
for better outcomes and I'm also looking
actively
we'll prepare legislation
in due course at what if you like the
mediation is the carrot what is the
stick's not quite where I were but the
check so that you don't get people going
into mediation they resolve the issue or
they get on the cusp of resolution but
they think they'll double dip and have
another crack just in case they could
get something better in court whether
it's cost shifting or fees I need to
look and see how we get the right
balance between the incentivization to
go through mediation and then settle and
the disincentive to then go to court
just because you want another bite of
the cherry and of course as you know
with private family law you're dealing
with very entrenched disputes and you
want to create a virtuous cycle of
resolution not a vicious cycle of
continuing the acrimony in court
particularly as I say in
non-safeguarding non-abuse cases where
children are at stake
worthwhile sentiments but what money is
the Lord Chancellor's Department
spending to ensure the diversion of the
45 percent of non-domestic abuse private
law family cases away from the courts
into a mediated or alternative dispute
resolution doing the allocations now but
they're not spending money at the moment
they are on the how much I can send I
can I let me follow up with the detail
um but I'm very happy to do that but I'm
also doing the allocations now how we
expand the current Pilots I'm sure it
works only Pilots
forgive me I've I've jammed up on uh the
detail of all the Constitutional issues
um but I'd need the figures at hand to
see what quite the scope is we've done
Pilots I now want to roll it out let me
come back to the detail but I hope you
get the broad sense that that's quite a
good example of a pretty substantial
structural reform that we'll make and I
definitely accept will need to invest in
the mediation to make it work I think it
will save us money uh several times over
and I'm very closely engaged with the
president the family law division on
this and in the meantime
in the meantime we're rolling out and
expanding the pilots and therefore
hopefully reducing I'm saying in the
meantime what about those people who
can't get lawyers who end up in a
situation where
for example they're not entitled to
domestic abuse uh
representation and advice so they're
ending up in a situation where they're
not properly represented in a dispute
for example about access to children for
example about the division of assets
yeah sure the existing legal aid
arrangements are there I think they are
inadequate well I look I I think for the
long term we need to make the structural
changes that we describe but if you ask
me for the short term
um the the difference will be the wider
changes we're making in the civil law
area and including the means test review
but if you're if if your question is
um
how much money we're putting into the
mediation vouchers I'll come back to you
if your question is whether I'm
satisfied in the meantime we have the
right financial support for those that
do rely on legal aid I'm very happy to
give you a a fuller answer in the same
letter in just sorry public law children
cases okay but that's different that is
different there is a sense is there not
that because of the post-pandemic
problems
and a whole range of other problems
which predate the pandemic the public
law children cases are now not being
dealt with sufficiently speedily and
they're not being properly resourced and
give me uh I thought you referred to
custody rather than guardianship no
public law where the state is
understanding so that's not sorry and
ship orders yeah only God that is not
quite what I thought you said earlier I
thought it was about private family I'm
happy to write uh about the investment
going into that as well okay yeah
I know that's an issue for quite a few
people outside this committee as well
um we need to move on to the next
question I'm afraid but um you know the
Constitution committee is on record of
expressing its concern consistently
about the situation in civil and
criminal legal aid impacting on
administration of justice
and that crystallizing into an
unsustainable position
um and although we've listened to your
answers I mean if you want to make any
final comments
as to what you would reassure us that
you will not end that we will not end up
in an unsustainable position we're also
monitoring it very carefully
um whilst the review of civil legal aid
is underway We are continuing to make
the best of the financial envelope we've
got just to give you one example of that
which I think is acute and sensitive
we're injecting 10 million pounds a year
into the housing legal aid through the
housing possession Court Duty scheme
there's 13 an additional 13 million
going into family legal aid so I mean I
hope I can reassure you that I'm keeping
it very closely under review
yeah okay thank you very much if we can
move on to court funding now
um Verona I think you had an
opening question on that
yes um good morning Lord Chancellor in
the in the upcoming spring budget how do
you plan to ensure effective and
efficient support for the courts and in
particular for Capital spending on the
the courts estate the outgoing chief
executive of his majesties courts and
tribunal Service as previously said that
there are approximately one billion
pounds of outstanding maintenance in the
Court's estate
yes look it's a very important issue
it's one of those issues which as Lord
Chancellor you you realize is
disproportionately uh relevant not just
to
um effectiveness of the courts but also
to the morale and the ability to recruit
judges after if you like paying pensions
Court maintenance the state of the
courtroom is probably the single
strongest most prevalent bit of feedback
I get the other point I always make to
our friends in the treasury is that uh
Court mate is the same with prison
maintenance if you lose a courtroom
because of uh Court maintenance issues
it is a totally false economy
um so I can't speak to what will be in
the current budget the forthcoming
budget but what what I can tell you is
um that we've spent 184 million on court
maintenance and repairs in the two years
to uh April 2023 so that that we will
have spent that much our current 2020 2
2023 budget for Capital maintenance and
Estates projects is 75 million pounds
and we have the whole pipeline of works
and we prioritize those uh very
carefully to maximize the functionality
of this data and the resilience there's
also an extra 20 million spent on
Capital maintenance in 2022-2023 on if
you if you like
I hesitate to see more minor issues but
repairs and replacement of items like
decorating replacing carpets Furniture
the Deep cleans uh making sure the fire
doors work as well as the larger scale
projects
um I think it is a a it's an issue I
discussed with the Judiciary quite a lot
as well as in the context of hmcts and
we certainly strive within our budgetary
envelope and frankly as a matter of the
Concord at to make sure that we're
providing enough to go in and I'm
entirely convinced that notwithstanding
the reticence about spending in capital
during a difficult Financial period that
actually it is really part of the
running costs and the operational
functionality of the courts
um and again I have regular discussions
uh in the last hmcts
board meeting we discussed this as one
of the the significant issues
what one of the issues that the
constitution committee has reported on
before is this keenness on understanding
the investment in I.T and in digital
enhancement in the court system its
impact on efficiency throughput and and
data collection to inform more
effectively informed policy and we have
seen the National Audit office report
which does Express concerns particularly
about the digital case management system
which of course is a key part of it
about improving efficiency would you
want to comment on that yes um
IT projects in Whitehall have a long and
and less than illustrious track record I
would say in the context of the justice
system and the court service it is
absolutely imperative uh that we keep
pursuing learn the lessons but keep
pursuing them there's a whole range of
issues around the common platform but
frankly I just will not succumb to the
Luddite view that we abandoned that
we've got to make it work there are
examples of good progress I think we
need to get these pace of that right
because we carry people with us but I
think that's important in The Wider
court system there's obviously areas
where it's working quite effectively
divorce proceedings the digitalization
in there actually there's some good
stats on on how that's being taken up uh
a probate is another area of course in
all of these areas there is a slightly
if I may say both amongst the clientele
and the those managing the system there
is a demographic uh difference in View
and approach but we have a master of the
roles who is very much a Pioneer and
Trailblazer in terms of encouraging
digitization and I.T reform and I think
that is certainly buoyed me when we've
had challenges so there's a lot more to
do but there is progress and I don't
think the situation is black and white
as sometimes presented but there's all
sorts of frustrations with it and we
need to increase if you like the digital
capacity of the users to make the very
best of it as well as deliver things
like common platform and the other
digitization processes but I don't think
we've got a choice
and the sort of the worst if you like
vested ludite sort of critique I think
we need to be quite clear we're taking
on but at the same time I'm also
sensitive to the whole point about
learning lessons and getting the pace of
Reform right
thank you if we could move on to court
backlogs Lord Minecraft I think we had a
question thank you
um good morning little chance that
there's a growing amount of anecdotal
evidence
the newspapers about the long jams and
delays at all levels in the court system
so could I ask you please what is the
current state of of the backlogs in the
court system are there any areas which
are particularly under intense pressure
and and what steps are you taking to
address this problem thank you very much
um so the outstanding case load in the
Crown Court increased
um I mean obviously let's take a step
back obviously there's a backlog before
the pandemic you always want an element
of backlog because otherwise scheduling
becomes a problem
um but clearly the pandemic and for
example the impact in jury trials of the
social distancing rules has increased
the backlog
um
we started to get it down it then
increased as a result of the CBA action
and at the end of October it was 62 500.
it's now decreasing uh in December it
was down to 61 700 our aim is to get it
down to 53 000 by 2025. there's a whole
range of things that we're doing to that
effect
um uh from uh Nightingale courts removal
of the the maximum limit on sitting days
I would say that the single biggest
issue is judicial Recruitment and I'm
working very closely with the Judiciary
on that
um in the magistrates Court the
outstanding backlog fell from a peak of
000 in July 2020 to 342 200 at the end
of December 2022 so still a way to go
but that was progress
in in family law the outstanding case
load in private in November 2022 was 52
700 that was quite that was a slight
decrease but not as much as we would
like and we've talked through some of
the structural issues there
um and and I I can talk about about
other areas
um but the pandemic has clearly created
a problem I'm most concerned about the
Crown Court backlog
um but we do have a plan in place
um and whether it's judicial recruitment
or the Court's maintenance project we
spend a lot of time looking at it and we
will we will push everything to get down
to 53 000 by 2025.
um Lord hope has a question and also uh
following Lord hope Lord hard has a
question which probably extends the
issue to the question of judicial
appointments themselves but Lord hope do
you want to ask you yes I'd like to just
follow up a bit on the point you've
mentioned about recruitment of judges
because the Lord don't choose Justice
last year told us that there was a
shortfall in meeting the target
um for example in the case of Quran
Court Circuit judges he was he was told
us he was felt shot by turn which is
quite a significant figure when you
could consider the number of charge days
involved and also the in the county
court uh well short of the number of
salary judges that are needed now the
the problem seem to be that the
candidates which are coming from coming
forward with all the judicial
appointments commission uh were not not
enough of them were judged to be a
sufficient Merit to be appointed and
that suggests there's something wrong in
attracting the right people I wonder
whether you can allow identify beyond
the state of the buildings what are the
factors affect the shortfall and how
they could be corrected
uh so I I think um uh paying pensions
although of course we've uh introduced
significant reform in those areas and
state of the Court estate I think are
the three most uh uh uh uh
um significant perhaps there's
attitudely a change I don't know I don't
have any more anecdotal view about
um uh the the uh the esteem that that
it's held in I don't know seemed to me
the Judiciary held in very high esteem
by the public and there's quite a lot of
polling that bears that out
um so I I I think it would be important
to continue to try and disaggregate what
those factors are but just in terms of
what we're doing about it we're
recruiting up to a thousand judicial
office holders as part of the 2022-2023
recruitment program and uh I've approved
for 2023 2024 around
another recruitment of a thousand
vacancies we've done the other things
around the backlog but
um we've also approved for 2023 2024 for
the recruitment round uh a thousand
vacancies across all the jurisdictions
so that includes 70 record 70 circuit
charges 125 recorders
um we've got a as you probably know a
concerted recruitment campaign for more
magistrates
um we're aiming to get 4 000 over the
next few years we've invested the money
in to do that in terms of where we are
now obviously we wanted it very closely
the high cool is it full strength that's
good news Circuit Judge recruitment has
been challenging
in the last four years that's that's
that's true we've had shortfalls of
something like 23 or up to 23 percent
against the vacancy request so that's
something we're looking at very
carefully but we're quite optimistic
that for the current round we've got a
strong field of applicants and actually
the recruitment of Deputy High Court
judges and Recorders has actually been
pretty positive
um
we've increased uh I've approved the an
increase in the vacancy request as they
were actually more selectable candidates
so we've increased it from 125 to 172.
so some challenges there for sure but
it's not um it's not all quite as Bleak
as uh as might be thought at first blush
yes there is one point you haven't
mentioned and that is the natural pull
for Crown Court judges yes of course the
criminal bar which uh the suggestion is
shrinking for reasons of well understood
that lack of human erosion and so on is
that something that uh European
attention to yes and
um
again it comes to your pool of
practitioners will ultimately feed the
quality of the applicants that come
forward which touches on perhaps some of
the earlier comments that we were
discussing
um around structural reforms to to the
pool of practitioners but it is
something that I'm very mindful of
thank you very much
not hard
your Chancellor I'd like to ask you
about senior judicial appointments in
your written evidence to our recent
inquiry you said that that was not a
current priority
but no less an authority than baroness
Hale has said that the current
Arrangements place that all chances are
in an impossible position some of us who
sat on the previous inquiry had
reservations about the current position
and I for one was impressed by the
evidence of Jack straw who has written a
preface to a policy exchange document
with which I expect you're familiar
which suggests some modest reforms
um
do you have any plans despite what you
said in your written evidence to to look
at that issue no current plans but I'm
in the market for ideas I haven't read
Jack's uh forward I will I will um I
will take a look at it of course the
um the the most significant senior uh
recruitment process underways for the
law chief justice and actually that will
give me a a a good sense of
um of where we are
um but I think the the the the three
three key elements are pool of great
talents
um and making sure in a sort of
meritocratic way we encourage the best
people to come forward I think there's
also a diversity issue
um I'm not known for being a tick box uh
politician on these things but I think
structurally that's true probably
particularly for ethnic minority uh
members of the bar and the profession
although I think gender as well
um so I I we we you know I I'm certainly
in the market for ideas for reform I I
suspect you're touching on the the role
of the Lord Chancellor in it it's always
difficult because the the little
chancellors roll uh is
um quite a flexible malleable role but
on the one hand we want judges selected
on the basis of strict Merit
um equally there's ought to be some form
of democratic oversight uh uh over it
and I think the law chance is trying to
balance both of those things and It's
Tricky and I'm not sure you ever get a
perfect outcome but in practice for
example with the law Chief Justice's
recruitment I think we'll get an
exceptional candidate out of it and I
suppose what I'm worried about mostly is
what works in real time in front of me
um but I'm I'm certainly willing if
either this committee or individuals
like uh Jack straw have got ideas I'm
certainly willing to entertain them and
to consider them
thank you
um well this issue is commented on by
the Constitution Committee in its report
on the law chance from the Law Officers
so
um we do
the extent that you're considering
responding to that report we did
highlight our concerns around
[Music]
any changes impacting on the
politicization of judicial appointments
but um
by all means you know
when you reply to our report
um
on to retained EU law including the
position of judicial pensions Lord
Faulkner you had a question yes the
judicial pensions be paid judges
regulations 2017 will be repealed as you
know Lord Chancellor by the effect of
the retained EU law revocation and
Reform Bill and the consequence of that
repeal will be that the department or
whoever pays them will pay 3.5 billion
pounds or less on judicial pensions for
be paid judges what is your proposal or
what are your plans in relation to that
are you going to let it be repealed and
if you are going to let it be repealed
what are you going to do about the
pensions of prepaid judges
I may need to write to you about the
detail of this um but look the the
bottom line is that as again as I think
you know until March of last year vpay
judges were able to accrue those pension
entitlements under the fee pay judicial
pension scheme after that they've
accrued their entitlements in the new
scheme the new scheme is is not directly
affected by the bill but I am
considering the implications of the bill
um for the 2017 regulations which
underpin entitlements to benefit from
the old fee page additional pension
scheme so perhaps
are you saying that the judicial
pensions fee paid judges regulations
2017 will not automatically be repealed
by the retained EU law
bill when it becomes law from the let me
come back to you let me look at that
specifically and come back to you please
okay fair enough okay thank you
thank you um
a little strathc cry
ing thank you and uh and good morning
I'm I'm a new member of this committee
and this is the first of these evidence
taking sessions uh that I have attended
but I'd like to thank you very much
indeed for the clarity of your answers
uh and for coming along now continuing
on what um Lord uh Faulkner said about
the retained EU law revocation Reform
Bill it is as you can imagine a rising
great passions in the House of Lords
um so specifically have you identified
uh in the bill
um other uh pieces of legislation which
are due to be revoked and what are you
doing about that to mitigate the effects
or indeed to it to encourage them it's
just a an overall view of what is your
intention so we're looking at this now
and as certainly as it applies to the
ministry of Justice I've I've got four
principles first of all
um we need to respect our International
obligations including under the
withdrawal agreement if there is
retained to you law that is actually our
implementing legislation for that or
indeed other things
um that we have where we have
international obligations and and
sometimes the there was into I hadn't
quite realized this into this sometimes
it's called retained EU law but actually
it's implementing legislation there's
something tangential but nonetheless an
international obligation so we ought to
do that because that's obviously what we
should do in terms of maintaining our
International obligations my starting
point with the remainder is to look very
carefully at whether we can remove or
replace and I have two core principles
that guide me one is as a he committed
brexite is to look for can we do
something which is tailored to the UK
circumstances in a careful way which
adds value and unless I'm less
interested in the number if I'm really
honest with you but where does it add
value is there a regulatory change that
will benefit I don't know legal
practitioners or
UK consumers of legal services in some
way or shape or form or where for
example uh because we're not governed by
the EU we can do more internationally
so I will look for that benefit I've got
to be realistic with the time frame of
either 2023 or 2026 because you can
postpone it what can be done so what
I'll look for is where is the maximum
value added for either removing or
replacing and what's the time frame
within which we can in a responsible way
legislate and then the second principle
obviously is I I'm not looking to do it
for the sake of it there's an element of
legal uncertainty that follows all of
this after a period of dramatic change
so I have to balance if you like the
assessment that we do with the value
added with the inevitable uh issue of
legal certainty those are the two things
I think should be our guiding lights
okay
how do you finish your point
um I know you've got a hard stop at 11
45 and we'll meet that so
um my name is Andrews I think you had a
slightly wider question on retained you
Lord yeah good morning your Chancellor
this is something I think maybe Lord
Anderson
um some some departments have told us
actually we're deep into the committee
stage of the of the bill and it is
proving very Lively to say the least
um and uh we've had a minister for
example telling us that his approach in
his department is retained by default
rather than revoke by default so my
first question is actually do you have a
third principle to answer the two you've
just given us which is a choice between
those two as well and the second thing
is to go back in this question of legal
uncertainty you said right at the very
beginning that you were very anxious to
establish the balance between New
Opportunities and you've talked about
added value and the uh and the legal
certainty but we have had a huge amount
of lobbying of course from the legal
bodies themselves about instance issues
around legal uncertainty and we have
been debating
at some length already Notions of what
happens to caselo and interpretive law
in the general passage of choice so what
would be your response
or your reassurance
to this issue that we may be tipping
because of the timetable not least and
the speed that everyone's having to work
out on some of the real ambiguities
about retention and Amendment of the law
as well will be your results on that
point I think I think it's a good
challenge I hoped I touched on most of
this in my earlier answer but let me try
and break it unpack a little bit more
um I I don't start from a presumption of
retention I'm not sure why I would do
that
um what I would start with is
can we remove or replace in a way which
adds net value
and what I don't want to do is lazily
scrap or lazily retain lazy is too
strong where but you know what I mean
casually or or think that this is a you
know quite quite an exercise to do
there's a huge amount and we've actually
uh replaced or repealed a whole bunch
already uh in the ministry of justice so
I'll look at it it's all about the value
added to UK PLC and the UK more
generally
um and I but I certainly don't start
from a presumption to retain uh a more
likely a presumption to try and remove
or replace but again in a way where the
presumption sits doesn't really matter
what I'm really looking for is the value
added can we do it meaningfully in the
time frame either 2023 or postpone to
2026.
um the legal uncertainty point is
important because that goes to the net
value added if actually you're creating
such breathless change that we can't
yield the dividend from it then that
becomes kind of productive I mean just
to give you one example I met with City
UK yesterday
exactly the conversation we had and I'm
very happy to listen to practitioners
and uh in the city and elsewhere
could you give us an indication of how
many sets of regulations the ministry of
justice is concerned with in relation to
the EU retained law Bill and what
resource you've put on to looking at it
yes but I need to write to you I have
the numbers at my fingertips yesterday
um exactly I knew you would ask this
um let me add it to my to-do list to
follow up issues to write to you about
the bill does not allow for additional
burdens to be placed on any part of the
the totality there has to be a trade-off
between something that goes as well as
something that arrives in terms of new
it's obviously whatever it is how do you
reconcile that with your search for
evaluated what would you lose for
example if you could give us an example
what would you lose from from replacing
or retaining yeah if you if you took out
something
if it is gold plating particularly in
any event or particularly because we no
longer have the EU obligation
um so from a deregulatory point of view
uh I think I mean I would start from
presumption that we want less fewer
regulations unless there's a good case
for them I think that's a good Paradigm
actually for legislation more generally
and not one to hyperactively legislate I
want to see what's the tangible benefit
thank you you mentioned legal
uncertainty in relation to the rural
Bill and of course that arises not only
in relation to retained EU
legislation status instruments and so on
but also the directly effective EU
obligations whether they derive from the
treaty or from directives or indeed from
International agreements which are
removed by Clause 3
and I just wondered we haven't got on to
this yet in committee I anticipate we'll
get onto it tomorrow but it seems to me
the scope for legal uncertainty there is
at least as great as it is in relation
to the uh legislation first because how
does Clause 3 interrelate to Clause 7
Clause 3 seems to remove these rights
Clause 7 seems to give the judges the
choice whether they continue to apply
them or not but more fundamentally what
is the effect on our law going to be our
common law
interpenetrated for 50 years by these EU
obligations when the obligations are
simply wrenched out and I wondered if
you thought there might be some sense
not in abandoning the whole task because
it's too difficult nobody wants to do
that in taking our time
spelling out what the anticipated
consequences of removing each of these
rights is likely to be and then
proceeding a bit more deliberately and
with a bit more opportunity for
Parliament to have a look at what's
happening because of course one thing
about the sunset in Clause 3 is that it
can't be extended so look um
in one level it's uh I'd need to go back
and think about it and give it some
wider view I've looked at this
principally from the MOJ angle
inductively
um the only thing I would just gently
press back I think in any event a lot of
EU regulation created a measure of
uncertainty overall what
um
that is almost Superfluous or even more
uh questionable now that we're not a
member state but inevitably I don't feel
so strongly about that that I'm not
mindful of of the balance I'm not sure I
mean this is a you know I tend to be
pragmatic about all these things
um so what I think you need to do is
weigh up the the pros and the cons I
certainly do agree with you though Lord
Anderson that we ought to have an
empirical basis for it we ought to try
and search for value-added and uh
hopefully have convinced you that at
least in relation to the MOJ suede we've
done that funny enough I think if you do
you probably end up getting rid of more
than you suspected at the beginning as
long as you've got time where it needs
to be adapted rather than just repealed
to make sure that you really understand
what you're replacing with
yeah we don't have time to the beach but
I'm just conscious reflecting on the
report the Constitution committee wrote
on the retained EU law bill was the
issue of you know how far when you're
looking at Value add you take yourself
into policy changes that are not
appropriate to be dealt with by
delegated legislation but that's uh
another debate which we don't have time
for in three minutes or two minutes to
go that uh thought I would just flag it
um well registered yeah thank you
um could I just say that the question we
can't get to is judicial diversity and I
didn't want to rush it because it's a
really important issue judicial
diversity and it goes over the longer
term to confidence in
the administration of justice and and so
forth so if I may we will write to you
on that issue because in addition to any
opening question we would have had
supplementaries so if you don't mind if
we could write you on that in the
knowledge that it would be a public
response that you were giving to us if
that's okay
yes absolutely I mean just in a nutshell
the only point I would make is I take
this very seriously I'm as interested in
the if you like
um
gender ethnicity uh diversity I think
that has a that's obviously important
but also the broader if you like class
access if I can put it that way why does
social access to what is otherwise
regarded as a rather causative
profession because I'm failure unfairly
so we
we're leading the pre-application
judicial education program so that tries
to support lawyers from underrepresented
groups to to think about whether
actually you know they should be
dreaming and aspiring to become a judge
um and I mean my my loving with Silex
continues
um I wrote a meritocrats Manifesto in
2012 about how we needed to create more
uh non-graduate routes into the legal
profession and I and I'm thinking about
that
because it's a good idea in the
profession but also what that means in
terms of the lead-in to the pool of
judicial Talent so perhaps without I'm
very happy to respond to your question
but just to give you a sense that I'm we
are thinking about it thoughtfully in a
considered way
um there's just a couple of things that
we're doing
no I mean that's an excellent point I
mean the issue of wider access and
um barriers right through the supply
chain is really important to this
um and that's very good to hear that
comment uh from you but I'm very
conscious people are interested in this
and I wouldn't want them to think that
we wouldn't give it due consideration so
if I may we'll write and we look forward
to your answer
um but I know you have to go thank you
very much indeed you've um
foresomely answered our questions which
is appreciated and thank you very much
indeed Richard thank you all uh great
pleasure and I look forward to coming
back again okay thank you